dump the food right on the table  and it's supposed to be some kind of new  diet thing  it's not a diet thing it's people  that are so lazy  and think that they have to do anything  to make their children eat  it's it's it's common this is a common  problem parents have with children  getting the kid to eat you sit here  until you eat dinner you have to eat  dinner and you have to eat the dinner  we're serving you because that's the  balanced meal we're providing you too  bad you want McDonald's tonight it's  disgusting  disgusting people are disgusting uh Pat  Walsh always says you can't leave the  house and he's right you can't leave the  house anymore I can't I can't look at  anything anymore